a lot of backlash for texas governor
abbott's decision
california's governor democrat gavin
newsom
called it absolutely reckless newsome of
course
has ordered some of the nation's
strictest lockdowns meanwhile one health
official in texas
is warning people not to change their
behavior just yet
saying quote despite the impending
removal of the state mask mandate we
must continue with our
vigilance with masking distancing and
hand washing
ken paxton texas attorney general joins
me now first of all
talk with me about meeting that backlash
with the facts that you and texas are
working with
yeah so i mean whenever you do something
related to cove but you're going to get
backlash
one way or the other no one's done this
perfectly no one knew how to do this
perfectly so
whatever you do you always get criticism
but i do think governor abbott's moved
in the
absolute right direction was giving
putting the the decision
in the hands of people who need to make
the decisions about themselves about
their own lives
letting business owners decide what they
want to do if they want to have
restrictions they can and then consumers
can decide if they want to
show up so i think this was a very good
decision and i think it's the direction
that we needed to go
you know i want to throw this into the
mix because it's about the facts
according to the cdc deaths per 100 000
people in your state
texas and florida are about 140
which is similar to the states with some
of the strictest lockdowns in the nation
california 132 deaths per 100
000. new york 163.
what do you make of that well i mean
those were just
statistics they're facts about what is
actually happening and so i think
what that says is this is a
pandemic that was going to spread one
way or the other and there's certainly
things we can do to protect ourselves
but we can't protect everyone all the
time
and it is going to spread to some degree
so
as the numbers show it really hasn't
made that much difference which way
you've gone so that's another good
reason to let people go back to work and
i think ron desantis said it well
that not everybody can work by zoom and
there are plenty of people who have
suffered
economically and mentally because they
haven't been able to work
that's so interesting and and for those
governors those municipalities that
continue to have stricter lockdowns if
the facts bear out and you're saying
they show that it's about the same if
you don't have those really strict
lockdowns
i wonder when they start to follow the
science just a question
hopefully soon because i don't i don't
want people in other states to suffer
either
exactly it affects us all doesn't it fox
is confirming
biden's new border policy has allowed
more than a hundred migrants released
into the united states after testing
positive for coven 19.
and the tests are done in brownsville
texas an official there says the city
does not have the authority to stop
those migrants from traveling anywhere
within the u.s
some migrants have told border agents
they are headed to new jersey north
carolina maryland just to name a few
places
meanwhile dhs reportedly is warning the
biden administration
about an unprecedented surge of
unaccompanied migrant children
showing up on our southern border with
mexico however
president biden denies that there's even
a crisis
did you receive a briefing about the
border today uh
yes i did what did you learn a lot
first of all attorney general paxton i i
want to just
get your pushback on the crisis point of
this
again just looking at what's actually
happening
yeah from day one when the president
came out and said that he wasn't going
to enforce immigration law of course we
sued him
my my biggest concern one of my biggest
concerns was what about this health stat
status of the people coming across we
won't know it if we do we're not going
to stop them
and i thought even from his
administration that this was an
important issue and now suddenly it's
not we're going to let people come into
the country that may have coveted and
potentially spread it back into my state
in new jersey north carolina just like
you you discussed it's a big
big issue yeah you know i want to lean
into that just a little bit though
because the timing of this could not be
more precarious for your state you're
trying to do something for
americans in the state of texas letting
those businesses
regenerate themselves those that are
even possibly coming back
we pray that they are and all of the
things and letting that personal freedom
now there'll be some
talk about mask wearing but all of that
at a time when we're letting all these
people in and we can barely check them
yeah i think it's irresponsible on the
part of the president to let this happen
i mean he knows that we all know that
covet is an issue we've tried to do our
best to
to respond to it we've had all kinds of
restrictions we just talked about this
issue that we're
loosening up restrictions trying to get
businesses back on their feet
and then we're just going to let more
covet come into our country
it's i don't know how you explain that
other than to say that's
absolutely irresponsible on the part of
the president for letting this happen
real quickly before we move on i mean it
is a choice though i mean these are
american citizens who are already here
the decisions that are made in texas
these are people who are coming from
foreign countries and
we're making decisions that don't
correlate
with them being american citizens
because they're not
you've nailed it on the head it's
absolutely true first of all they
shouldn't be here anyway they shouldn't
be
allowed to come across the board they're
not supposed to be according to our
injunction the president still
has to deport those people whether
that's actually happening we'll see as
we go along
but just the narrative that the
president is putting out that is
seemingly inviting people to come and
the numbers are starting to show it
it creates not just the coveted risk but
also human trafficking and
drugs and all kinds of crime issues that
my state now has to deal with
the ones we've been talking about all
along dhs reportedly projects a
record-breaking 117 thousand
unaccompanied minors will try to cross
into the united states this year
illegally last year that number was just
more than
thirty three thousand that is an
enormous
jump what's driving it
i think it's the president his
administration
basically saying you can come here and
and you're you're going to be fine we're
not going to deport you
we've tried to stop that but there's
still the message out there and so
you're going to have people because they
believe
that president biden wants them here
they're gonna come and it's so
such an inconvenient such a bad time for
him to have done that
because of the very issues we've just
talked about yeah real quickly i just
thought of a question previously
on what's happened in your state if you
start to see the numbers of covid go up
whether it's from people crossing into
your state
whatever the situation does that change
the idea about
mass mandate and the rest you know what
i'm hoping i hope
we move beyond that that individual
business owners can decide they can have
mass
mandates individuals can make decisions
for themselves about
what they want to do their health status
their age whether they have
risk factors and especially as the
vaccine becomes more prevalent i just
think it's time for individual
individual responsibility as opposed to
government oversight
attorney general of the great state of
texas ken paxton with us today good to
see you thank you
hey thank you